[Musique]
te dire que nous sommes entre colère et
découragement comprendre l'improbable et
surréaliste régime des fouilles
alors que plus de 90 mille objets madame
la garde des sceaux a été trouvé cette
haine et 40000 téléphones sont entrés
dans les prisons en 2017 orient ne parle
même pas de la créativité des détenus
créer des armes par destination avec
tout ce qui leur passe par la main sans
compter que nous n'avons toujours pas de
gilet par l'âme pour les gardiens et le
personnel pénitentiaire
comment expliquer également l'accès à
une unité de vie familiale pour un
criminel de cette nature et j'ajoute
deux fois par mois
comment expliquer les failles du
renseignement pénitentiaire alors que ce
détenu était été signalé pour ces faits
de radicalisation madame la ministre la
question que je voudrais vous poser
c'est quel calendrier et quelles mesures
avez-vous l'intention de prendre pour
que nos personnels pénitentiaires soient
mieux protégés qu'il n'est surtout pas
le sentiment que le confort des détenus
passent avant leur sécurité
nous avons renforcé la sécurité des
établissements nous déployons un système
de brouillage nouveau des téléphones
portables nous commençons à le déployer
à la prison de la santé à vendin le
vieil
et nous allons continuer nous avons un
dispositif de lutte contre les drones
nous avons accru de plus de 16% le
budget de sécurité des établissements
pénitentiaires et nous allons continuer
nous avons enfin pris des mesures c'est
le troisième point pour protéger nos
personnels pénitentiaires ces mesures de
protection contrairement à ce que vous
avez affirmé à l'instant passe notamment
par le déploiement d'équipements
nouveaux gilets pare-balles tenu par
coup plus de 1500 gillet par pardon par
là mais excusez moi pas par balles par
l'âme
plus de 1500 gillet ont été déployés
cela doit continuer et il y a également
d'autres mesures qui sont prises dans ce
sens la sécurité des français et notre
priorité celles des personnels
pénitentiaires l'est tout autant madame
nationale
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
doit être appréhendée de manière globale
en incluant les individus les
travailleurs sociaux les magistrats les
forces de l'ordre les associations selon
le lâcher seuls 80 millions d'euros des
crédits sur les 420 millions pour
l'égalité sont alloués chaque année à la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
il faudrait cinq fois plus de moyens car
la mise en place de politiques publiques
un réel impact sur la hausse ou la
baisse du nombre de victimes
c'est pourquoi je vous pose la question
à la veille de cette journée hautement
symbolique
le gouvernement se donne t'il réellement
les moyens de lutter contre les
féminicides vous m'interrogez sur les
violences faites aux femmes sur les
féminicides nous sommes engagés très
rapidement sur la création de centres de
prise en charge du psycho traumatismes
notamment dédié aux femmes victimes de
violences sexuelles est fictive de
victimes de violence tous coups de leur
conjoint nous avons fait un appel à
projet n'a pas la candidature l'année
dernière ces dix centres ont été créés
labellisés nous sommes le premier pays
au monde à organiser des réseaux de
prise en charge des victimes de psycho
traumatisme c'est une mesure
emblématique sur lequel il y avait un
engagement du président de la république
lors du lancement de novembre 2017 et
donc le gouvernement est totalement
mobilisée pour réduire évidemment les
violences faites aux femmes
[Musique]